[Musique]
Artem studikov bonjour nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
Youtube qui s'appelle on voudrait avoir
votre point de vue sur la géopolitique
mondiale sur l'actualité comment ça va
comment allez-vous qu'est-ce qui se
passe en Russie qu'est-ce qui se passe
un peu partout dans le monde bonjour et
comme d'habitude je vous remercie de de
m'avoir invité à ma
personne l'ambassade de Russie si vous
voulez à Paris vous êtes le numéro 2 de
l'ambassade de Russie tout à fait c'est
comme ça c'est mon 3è poste en France
et depuis octobre 2015 j'assume les
responsabilités du ministre conseiller
chef de mission adjoint de l'ambassade
de Russie en France donc écoutez euh euh
comment comment ça va vous avez vous
avez dit bah globalement évidemment
comme tout le monde répond ça va bien
mais euh si on prend l'aspect
international si on prend la situation
dans le monde donc euh ça va pas très
bien euh à notre avis parce que le monde
devient de plus en plus instable les
conflits se multiplient euh la situation
euh devient de plus de plus en plus
compliqué dans plusieurs pays du monde
mais tout d'abord évidemment dans cette
région qui était toujours assez
compliqué mais aujourd'hui il est devenu
vraiment notre problème numéro 1 pour
tout le monde c'est le proche
Moyen-Orient euh cette région depuis
plusieurs années est déjà est
déstabilisé et euh si autrefois à
l'époque on pouvait euh parler de cette
crise
arabo israélien ou
palestino-israélien euh il y avait cette
guerre entre Irak et Iran mais à part ça
la région était plus ou moins euh stable
même si nous prenons l'Afghanistan euh à
l'époque de cette
euh cette entrée des forces soviétiques
en Afghanistan même à l'époque là la
situation en Afghanistan était beaucoup
plus stable qu'aujourd'hui euh
donc nous constatons une crise énorme
autour de la syérie une crise qui
implique plusieurs pays de la
région nous constatons la guerre sans
fin au Yémen la guerre oublié par tout
le monde tandis que là les pertes
humanitaires les pertes de la population
civile euh se calcule déjà par par des
milliers et des milliers euh et euh tout
ça euh tous ces victimes tous ces pertes
euh c'est le résultat de cette opération
menée par euh l'Arabie Saoudite
euh tout le monde euh est conscient et
en même temps euh tout le monde ne parle
pas de ces bombardements aveugles qui se
produisent tout le temps dans cette
région de péninsule
euh arabique euh nous avons euh la la
situation
euh très urgente et euh très aigu en
Libye euh on a constaté la
défragmentation de ce pays après
euh après l'entrée dans le jeu euh des
pays occidentaux surtout de la France et
la Grande-Bretagne qui ont contribué au
chutees du régime de Kaddafi mais qui
n'ont pas épaulé euh les nouvelles
autorités du puis dans la reconstruction
de Libye donc en résultat nous avons euh
en chaos évidemment aujourd'hui la
société internationale a fait beaucoup
pour essayer de prendre les choses en
main et euh pour aider le gouvernement
provisoire de prendre sous leur contrôle
la situation en pays mais vous savez
très bien qu'il y a un facteur des
dicadistes
internationaux il y a le facteur de sép
de de cette défragmentation du pays de
ce conflit euh larvé entre tobrou et
Tripoli donc la situation est très très
compliquée dans cette région et en même
temps euh cette déstabilisation de la
Libye a renforcé les forces radicales
les forces extrémistes euh dans
certaines régions de l'Afrique
équatoriale je parle
euh je parle de du Mali je parle de
Nigéria du Cameroun du Tchad avec cette
organisation euh qui est rattaché à
Al-Qaïda Boko Haram justement donc vous
voyez cette
instabilité dans dans la région du proch
moyen arient a déjà des conséquences
pour les régions beaucoup plus
éloigné j'ai pas évoqué mais il faut le
faire les tensions entre l'Arabie
Saoudite et l'Iran
euh en réalité c'est presque la guerre
en procuration ce que nous voyons au
Yémen par proxy par par proxy justement
c'est c'est un pays où se Orte les
intérêts de l' de l'Arabie Saoudite
sunnite et de l'Iran chiite il faut pas
oublier le Liban qui est toujours où la
situation reste très fragile à cause de
cette crise politique interne sans fin
l'absence du président euh
nous nous devons évidemment évoquer de
l'Afghanistan où les forces de taliban
ont pris sur le contrôle kundous et
maintenant l'armée se bat pour
reprendre cette ville très importante en
Afghanistan mais toute cette situation
nous démontre combien la situation est
compliquée en Afghanistan
euh la France avec les autres
partenaires de la colaltion se prépare à
épauler les forces iraakiens à reprendre
Mossou euh la plus grande une des plus
grandes pays de l'Irak pris pris prise
par par l'État islamique par par le
daesh donc voyez nous pouvons continuer
à parler de tout ce de toutous Cees
problèmes innombrabl de la région qui
déstabilise non seulement la région mais
qui crée des tensions à l'échelle
mondiale je je voudrais qu'on aborde
l'aspect de
déstabilisation par des facteurs
extérieurs par proxy
on entend dire qu'il y a 89 nationalités
de djihadistes en Syrie quel est votre
point de vue quels sont leurs modes de
financement et qui tire les
ficelles
là nous connaissons ce
problème selon notre propre expérience
parce que on a déjà rencontré ce
phénomène des
djikadistes étrangers en tchichini euh
surtout lors de la deuxème opération
antiterroriste à tichini parce que là
euh on a rencontré pas mal des gens de
ce type-là euh et
euh certains parmi eux ont occupé une
place importante dans le système
hiérarchique du commandement des
rebelles des terroristes
entigéie donc euh pour nous euh c'est
pas euh c'est pas notre première
expérience mais euh effectivement euh ce
phénomène euh a euh en série a connu
vraiment euh euh en grand euh
essort en grand succès si on peut le
dire parce que euh selon notre euh
estimation une grande partie euh des
gens armés qui luttent aujourd'hui
contre le gouvernement de Damas euh je
peux pas vous donner le pourcentage mais
en tout cas il s'agit de dizaines de
pourcents ce sont des étrangers venus de
différents coins du monde pour euh
combattre pour cette cause euh du daesh
de l'État islamique pour la création de
khalifat
euh mondial parce que initialement vous
savez que cette organisation
s'appelait état islamique de lesévante
et de Liban euh et de Syrie et de et de
l'vent c'est-à-dire le vent
c'està-dire il se proposait de créer un
califat sur le territoire assez limité
donc mais après ils ont changé d'avis
ils ont rebaptisé leur mouvement euh en
le nommant tout simplement l'État
islamique
euh tout en comprenant que euh euh la
région limitée c'est pas suffisante euh
c'est pas suffisant il faut tout
simplement créer en califat en état
islamique à l'échelle mondiale et
c'était la raison euh de notre décision
euh
[Musique]
assez difficile à prendre devenir en
force en srie pour euh soutenir euh le
gouvernement légitime de ce pays pour
éviter l'effondrement total de l'État
syrien et pour ne pas créer
euh la base pour H l'élergissement euh
du zone de contrôle euh de l'État
islamique sur toute la région parce que
nous sommes profondément persuadés que
euh la l'opposition soi-disant modérée
euh syrien qui d'ailleurs euh existe euh
euh je pense que c'est une réalité mais
nous sommes profondément persuadés que
euh la les capacités de cette opposition
modérée estant comparable avec les
capacités de l'État islamique et au cas
de l'effondrement de l'État syrien
euh cette opposition modérée serait
rasée de la carte politique de Syrie par
euh le mouvement de l'État islamique par
le mouvement du daesh et après c Liban à
après c'est l'Arabie Saoudite après
c'est l'Égypte où la situation aussi
reste très très fragile donc c'était la
raison de
notre implication dans le conflit syrien
au côté de l'armée de Bachar al-Assad
euh justement parce
que nous savons très bien que
l'opposition armée radicale et euh non
pas radicale est soutenue par les
sponsur étrangers quels sont les
sponsors euh écoutez
euh nous avons plusieurs euh euh
plusieurs informations qui émanent de
différentes sources euh que le soutien
provient de certains pays du Golf
lesquels euh écoutez j'aimerais bien de
ne pas citer ces pays euh parce que vous
comprenez très bien qu'il faut donner
des preuves concrètes euh je pense que
euh les services les autorités
compétentes en
France aux États-Unis et en Russie
possède de telles informations mais là
je ne veux pas citer les pays vous les
connaissez très bien de ces pays et les
internautes euh qui
surfent sur Internet ont lu pas mal
d'informations on lu pas mal de de
de pas mal de rumeurs pas mal de
d'informations plus ou moins
convinquante concernant ce sujet mais
nous comprenons très bien que toutes ces
armes tout ce financement euh t ces
munitions ils ne peuvent pas parvenir du
ciel euh évidemment il y a des trophées
de guerre mais il y a on soutient en
logistique euh qui euh arrive qui arrivé
dès le début de cette guerre civile en
Syrie euh pour nous c'est un des
facteurs qui nous a fait prendre cette
décision comme je vous dis difficile à
prendre parce que après notre expérience
en Afghanistan envoyé notre troupe
envoyé nos
pilotes à centaines kilomètres à
centaines à milliers kilomètres de la
Russie en Syrie c'est une risque mais
c'est une risque pour nous raisonnable
parce que il faut pas oublier que ce qui
se passe en Syrie se trouve ou plutôt la
Syrie se trouve à 800 km de la frontière
russe et pour nous la lutte contre
l'État islamique en Syrie signifie la
lutte contre les futurs djihadistes qui
pourrait un jour
venir venir déstabiliser les pays
limitrophes de la Russie c'està-dire les
pays de l'Asie centrale aussi bien que
la Russie comme telle on a vu on a vu
récemment la crise se polariser avec
vraiment une augmentation des tensions
avec la Syrie entre les États-Unis et la
Russie la question que je vais vous
poser qui est très directe est-ce que
vous êtes en train de vous apparît un
conflit ouvert nucléaire avec les
États-Unis bien sûr que non euh moi je
disais de je me souviens plus si j'ai
évoqué ce sujet lors de ma
précédente visite chez vous mais moi je
pense que c'est une c'est un sujet tabou
nous tous nous
devons bien comprendre que cette option
est est absolument
impossible il faut pas même envisager
cette option non il faut pas le faire
parce que là nous n'avons aucune raison
de parler de cette option horrible je
refuse en tout cas de d'évoquer et de
d'analyser les l'éventualité de cette
tournure de choses mais mais
effectivement euh les tensions ont
beaucoup monté depuis quelques quelques
temps entre la Russie et les États-Unis
euh après h après la fin de ce se fait
le feu euh euh qui était le résultat des
langues tractation des langues
négociations entre les chefs de la
diplomatie russe et américaine j'ai j'ai
j'ai nous avons annoncé votre venue sur
internet depuis mercredi d'ailleurs
merci d'avoir répondu aussi vite à notre
sollicitation les internautes nous ont
fait remonter énormément de coupures de
presse ruses tant ruses qu'anglaise
américaine j'ai pu voir passer de devant
mes yeux des exercices militaires en
Russie qui engageraient 40 millions
civil euh 200 ou 300000 personnels
militaires 40 millions de civils oui euh
en quelle forme euh participation
d'exercice de de de frappe sur votre
territoire puis j'ai vu
euh passer des papiers d'ailleurs Rusia
today a posté il y a pas pas loin d'une
demi-heure que des déclarations de
généraux américains qui expliquait si
vous voulez que je vous donne exactement
le le titre qui expliquait que la les
généraux américains de points un conflit
extrêmement meurtri avec la Russie est
quasiment certain h écoutez là je ne
peux pas commenter les paroles des
généraux américains les généraux russes
ne parlent pas de
cette
éventualité les généraux russes prévient
que nous avons suffisamment de moyens en
Syrie pour riposter au cas où euh mais
nous avons ces moyens depuis le début de
notre opération en Syrie euh le conflit
ou plutôt euh euh les euh les incidents
euh sont toujours possibles et voilà
pourquoi même après l'arrêt des euh des
négociations entre la Russie et les
États-Unis sur plutonium comment sur le
plutonium non non non euh là il y avait
pas des des négociations il avait on
traité mais non je parle de la Syrie
l'arrêt des négociations de cet échange
continue entre euh les deux ministères
des Affaires étrangères et les deux
euh ministères de la Défense euh ne
signifie pas l'arrêt des contacts entre
les entre les militaires pour assurer le
déconflicting pour la déconflictation
dans le cadre de des des des agréments
sur le sur sur la déconflictation
c'est-à-dire et les Américains les
Russes comprend très bien que euh la
situation où euh l'avéation de deux pays
est pr présent dans le ciel syrien parce
que les Américains emènent leur propre
opération antiterroriste et la Russie
effectue sa propre opération
antiterroriste à côté du gouvernement
légitime syrien donc la présence de deux
avéations dans le ciel euh de la Syrie
demande en contact permanent entre
militaires entre les militaires pour
éviter les incidents les conflits pour
assurer cette déconflictation et je
voudrais bien mettre l'accent sur ce
fait donc euh d'abord on continue à
parler avec les Américains en principe
sur la série et nos deux ministres des
affaires des Affaires étrangères ont
déjà se sont déjà échangé des coups de
fil après euh l'annonce par les
autorités américaines de l'arrêt euh de
ces contacts sur euh sur le sfeu euh
donc il Contin nous continuons à parler
avec les Américains et les militaires
continuent à se contacter pour éviter
euh justement les accrochages
euh par erreur des bavures et c'est une
erreur que votre ambassade en Syrie é
est été bombardée non selon notre selon
notre avis c'était une
action préparée effectuée par japrat
nousra qui a changé un petit peu son nom
son étiquette mais
pas et le fait que les États-Unis
bloquent la condamnation par à l'ONU
qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait bah écoutez
pour nous cela reflète la politique
embigu des États-Unis la politique de
double standard
euh les États-Unis ont démontré une
nouvelle fois que ils ont des relations
très euh très ambivalentes à l'égard de
l'opposition radicale
syrienne oui c'est dommage c'est dommage
mais c'est pas pour la première fois
et on espérait de convaincre les
américain de de soutenir cette
résolution plutôt cette
déclaration qui qui juste met l'accent
sur la nécessité de respecter la
convention de Vienne et qui
soulligne le statut spécifique des
ambassades dans tout le monde et compris
en Syrie ils n'ont pas soutenu leur
notre projet ou plutôt ils ont voulu
d'introduire certains dispositions qui
n'étaient pas acceptables pour la partie
russe et voilà pourquoiqu lesquel euh
sur la sur la responsabilité de la
Russie euh pour cette regain de tension
en Syrie voilà pour pour pour dire si
vous voulez pour dire si vous voulez que
c'est notre tort que c'est c'est notre
responsabilité le fait que l'ambassade
de Russie a été bombardée c'est le
résultat des démarches des des activités
russes en Syrie voilà c'était l'idée
américain tandis que pour nous c'était
pas acceptable on voulait juste accuser
l'attaque contre la représentation
diplomatique parce que on sait jamais
dans n'importe quel pays du monde
n'importe quel représentation
diplomatique pourrait être attaqué et si
nous si nous ne réagissons pas à ce type
d'action
euh cela peut amener à des à des choses
inacceptables quand votre commandement
en Syrie a annoncé qu'il abattrait tout
avion et tout missile en direction de
Bachar elAssad de son armée comment les
Américains ont perçu ça maintenant que
vous avez mis des S300 et des S400 je
crois bien maintenant sont arrivés en
voilà justement je voulais euh ce que
j'ai dit déjà S400 était présent sur le
sol syrien dès le début de l'opération
ou en tout cas très très rapide très
rapidement après le début de l'opération
es300 était arrivé avec l'avéation russe
pour
assurer la protection de notre base
voilà écoutez euh oui on a prévenu euh
tous les pays impliqués dans le conflit
euh dans la situation en Syrie dans le
conflit syrien que les frappes contre
l'armée syrienne
contre le gouvernement légitime
syrien aura des conséquences néfastes
pour pour la région et pour la Syrie en
ce qui
concerne la pratique j'espère que
personne ne va
pas aller vers l'aggravation de la
situation j'espère que euh nous allons
continuer ensemble des efforts conjoints
pour euh essayer de trouver
euh la solution pour essayer de baisser
les tensions et la Russie se prononce
pour h pour la continuation euh des pour
parler sur la Syrie euh euh entre les
acteurs clés et entre euh les forces
syrienes syriennes y compris le
gouvernement et les différentes euh
branche de l'opposition sauf évidemment
euh les groupes reconnus comme
terroristes euh par euh l'Organisation
des Nations
Unies la France dans la région quel est
votre regard sur la diplomatie
française vous voyez que
euh vous avez vu évidemment que euh
ministre des Affaires étrangères euh
Monsieur H a été accui à Moscou par euh
par Monsieur Lavrov par notre ministre
des Affaires étrangères euh c'est une
visite éclaire et nous avons accepté
immédiatement après la démand de nos
partenaires français donc vous voyez que
le dialogue très dense euh euh continue
euh nous n et ici à Paris nous en tant
que l'ambassade nous sommes en contact
permanent avec nos partenaires et
collègues français euh à l'ONU aussi il
y on travail entre les représentations
permanentes euh euh de la Russie de la
France à New York partout nous parlons
partout nous échangeons des idées de nos
évaluations des choses mais on constate
que la politique française n'a pas
beaucoup bougé dès le début du conflit
euh la France met toujours sur le départ
de Bachar al-Assad sans réfléchir à
l'avenir de la syérie dans cette
situationl par contre la sit la
l'approche français a évolué en quelque
sorte parce que initialement la France
exigeait le départ immédiat de Bachar
al-Assad aujourd'hui euh c'est pas une
condition préalable pour le début des
des des négociations
entre pour le début de ce dialogue C
dialogue
intersyrienne non aujourd'hui la France
reconnaît que Bachar alAssad peut rester
au pouvoir euh en tout cas au début
desess pour parler et pas c'est pour
parler mais euh Paris exige toujours le
départ de Bachar
al-Assad nos partenaires français pour
l'URE actuelle ne peuvent pas imaginer
que Bachar al-Assad pourrait prendre
part aux élections présidentielles
organisées selon conformément
à à l'accord entre toutes les forces
ériennes
euh de ce point de vue Paris reste sur
le même euh sur la même position mais en
même temps nous partageons avec la
France euh une idée sur la syérie de
futur euh sur la syérie de l'avenir
c'est la syérie unifiée euh la syérie
qui respecte toutes les minorités
ethniques et toutes les confessions
religieuses euh c'est la syérie
démocratique et laïque euh notre analyse
ou plutôt nos souhaits sont les mêmes
euh nos approches sont différents
comment aboutir à cette série comment
aboutir à la fin des hostilités à la fin
de la guerre
civile là effectivement elle est à
reconnaître c'est pas en secret nos
approches sont très
différents on a dismin la presse
occidentale et l'intelligencia française
a beaucoup reproché à la
Russie ce qui se passe à Halep quelle
est votre vision de ce qui se passe à
Alep est-ce que c'est un blitz creck
est-ce que c'est un bombardement total
et aveugle ou est-ce que vous suspectez
l'injection de de de l'État islamique à
travers les les fameux casques blancs
syriens quelle est votre lecture qui
qu'est-ce qui se passe écoutez euh pour
nous ce qui se passe à Halep aujourd'hui
c'est le résultat
euh des activités des groupes
terroristes infiltrés dans la ville et
qui aujourd'hui en réalité contrôle
cette partie d'Alep parce que c'est ce
sont les combattants de jabatan nusra
qui tient en main la situation dans
cette villeelà et malheureusement le
problème c'est que nos partenaires
américains n'ont pas réussi ce qu'ils
ont promis à faire depuis des mois déjà
séper les milices de l'opposition modéré
les troupes les les unités de
l'opposition
modérée des unités qui appartientent des
troupes qui
appartientent à cette organisation de
jafrat an nusra ça c'est le
problème primordial le problème crucial
nous avons demandé pendant des mois et
des mois à nos partenaires américains de
respecter leur partie de promesses parce
que nous avons fait tout ce que nous
pouvons faire avec nos partenaires
syriens on a demandé nos partenaires
sériens à arrêter les combats arrêter
les hostilités et la trêve a duré
quelques temps pendant la durée de cette
nouvelle trêve les l'opposition
euh modéré et radical qui se qui se'est
qui s'est mélangé déjà à Halep
euh a utilisé a profité de cette pause
pour renforcer ses positions tout en
continuant à attaquer
euh àep de de l'Est où se trouve pardon
àep de l'Ouest qui se trouve S contrôle
du gouvernement syrien en attaquant les
positions des troupes syriens et en en
renforçant ses positions partout dans
dans dans la région dans ce contexte
l'armée syrienne et sans
cette sans sans la mise en pratique de
cette promesse américain de séparer les
troupes des radicaux et des modérés
l'armée syrienne a été obligée de rompre
euh d'arrêter le le feu et de riposter
euh le résultat de cette riposte c'est
euh l'offensif effectué aujourd'hui par
l'armée syrienne à Halep en ce qui
concerne l'aviation l'utilisation de
l'aviation euh écoutez h je peux parler
pour l'aviation russe toutes nos frappes
que nous effectuons sont bien ciblés euh
ça c'est notre position de principe nous
travaillons a l'aviation russe travaille
uniquement sur les sites sur les cibles
euh qui ont été reconnu comme euh comme
si CBL appartenant comme des com comme
des comme des cibles légitimes comme des
cibles comme des positions des des
[Musique]
forcesat nousra comme des points de
commandement comme
des un stock de munition et cetera tel
est notre position si vous identifiez un
hôpital ou l'armée syrienne identifie un
hôpital comme un centre de commandement
ou une cache terroriste est-ce que vous
rasez
l'hôpital écoutez je suis pas militaire
je peux pas vous je suis pas sur le
terrain euh je n'ai pas de toute
information dans sa généralité
euh mais euh il faut être réaliste nous
sommes des réalistes pendant la guerre
tout peut arriver il y a des Bures vous
savez très bien que l'armée américaine a
bombardé les troupes syriens tuant 62
personnes et un blessant encore une
centaine de personnes c'est une bavure
les bavures sont possibles euh surtout
mais quand je quand je parle de
l'aviation russe je soulligne chaque
frappe est bien
préparé chaque frappe est effectuée à la
base des informations
euh que nous recevons par tous les
moyens possibles par utilisant tous les
moyens de renseignement
donc bien sûr nous voulons faire tout
pour minimiser les pertes chez les
civils je ne peux pas exclure que ces
pertes sont possibles mais en même temps
quand même il y a beaucoup de beaucoup
de propagande dans le contexte actuel à
Halep
écoutez
vraiment personne ne parle pas de la
situation au Yémen où l'avéation de
l'Arabie Saoudite de ses alliés par par
par cette coalition antiousite bombarde
chaque jour ou presque les diff
coin du du Yémen en tuant des centaines
et des centaines de civils en bombardant
des des hôpitaux des des des fêtes de
mariage tout ce que vous voulez personne
ne parle pas de cette
situation absolument scandaleuse la
Libye la Libye bon la Libye a été
bombardée il y a déjà un bon moment
mais la lib c'est plutôt un exemple de
ce qui peut arriver avec un pays si
l'engérance de l'extérieur n'est pas
accompagné par
euh par le concours politique au
redressement économique politique de ce
pays comment vous expliquez que la
presse française et occidentale ne ne se
polarise que sur la Syrie et oublie le
Yémen écoutez je ne peux pas dire que
Yémen est oublié de temps en temps
effectivement il y a des articles qui
apparaissent dans tous les grands
massmédias français mais oui c'est c'est
c'est écoutez c'est c'est de la
politique c'est la réalité de notre
temps oui tout le regard sont concentrés
sur la Syrie parce que Syrie c'est un
pays plus important plus peuplé au
centre de la région déjà
très difficile et Yemen il est quelque
part ailleurs est plus c'est une région
plus éloignée peut-être c'est cela qui
peut expliquer la situation par
contre effectivement je pense que
cette critique à l'égard de la Russie
parfois n'est pas très objectif et très
partiel je voudrais qu'on change de un
petit peu de région du monde j'aimerais
qu'on aborde les questions des troupes
de l'OTAN à la frontière
russe sur Internet on a vu depuis un
certain temps des convois de trains
remplis de chars aux couleurs forêt
verte pas aux couleur du désert se
dirigeant un peu vers vous euh comment
vous percevez ça euh écoutez oui tout ce
qui concerne le temps là je pense qu'il
faut examiner cette
situation dans toute sa complexité et il
faut commencer par les événements du
début des années 90
euh dans les années 90 quand
euh la le régime politique en Union
soviétique estchangé de façon
spectaculaire ou plutôt l'Union
soviétique a disparu et euh la
Fédération euh de Russie en quelque
sorte a pris sa place en tout cas
l'armée soviétique euh qui avait ses
bases et qui était stationné dans
certains pays de l'Europe de de l'Est
cette armée soviétique est devenue
l'armée russe et euh cette armée a été
évacué dans les meilleures conditions et
dans le meilleur délai peut-être même
euh leur départ des pays de l'Europe de
l'Est était mal préparé chez nous
parfois les les soldats et officiers
russes ont été obligé de passer
plusieurs mois dans les conditions
énormément difficiles parce que les
bases n'ont pas été préparées euh en
Russie mais on a fait tout ça euh parce
que c'était la période c'était l'époque
des illusions euh l'époque de romantisme
politique l'époque quand on
était persuadé que le monde change et
euh que
euh notre prise de position euh nos
décisions politiques euh seront
appréciées à leur juste titre par nos
partenaires
occidentaux il faut dire queautrefois à
l'époque au moment de la pestroïca
au moment de ce rapprochement entre
l'Occident et l'Union soviétique au
moment des rencontres de Gorbatchev avec
ses homologues occidentaux euh on lui a
promis de ne pas élargir le temps après
euh le départ des troupes soviétiques
euh par exemple de la République
démocratique Allemagne en vue de
réunification avec euh la République
fédérale allemande euh rien n'a été
signé rien n'a été promis
euh dans les lettres ou dans les
documents mais les paroles ont été
prononcé et il y a pas mal de témoins
qui confirment que ces promesses ont été
faites c'est important pour un Russe une
parole h oui oui tout ça je suis
d'accord avec vous mais je pense que
comme on dit les Français c'est un homme
de parole donc ça existe tout le un
homme sans parole un homme sans parole
est un homme qui ne vaut rien justement
et et voilà
gorbachchev a cru parce que je pense que
je me souviens très bien de cette
période là vraiment c'était le temps de
belles illusions et cétait c'était un
très bon temps parce que effectivement
après cette longue période de la
fermeture on a levé ce ride de faire on
a fait des frontières transparentes et
on attendait des pas
euh réciproqu du côté de nos partenaires
occidentaux qu'est-ce que nous avons
qu'est-ce que nous avons vu en réponse
élargissement de le temp élargissement
qui ne s'arrête pas qui ne s'arrête pas
aujourd'hui
euh on a vu d'abord les pays de
l'Europe de certains de l'Europe de de
l'Est entrer à le temps les pays
exrépublique de l'Union soviétique qui
ont des frontières communes avec la
Russie actuelle on a vu les tentatives
de faire entrer dans le temps certains
pays qui
est qui qui qui faisait partie même de
la Communauté des États indépendantes
euh CEI c'est-à-dire la geéorgie
l'Ukraine on parle de la Moldavie aussi
donc tout ça a été très mal perçu par
par la population russe parce que c'est
pas la Russie qui s'approche aujourd'hui
vers les front de le temps mais c'est le
temps qui rapproche qui se rapproche
vers les frontières de la Russie
euh vous savez peut-être vous savez que
en en
1980 14 on a signé un accord fondateur
en acte
fondateur entre la Russie et le temps
qui prévoyait la création de cet
institut comme conseil Russie aut temp
euh qui devrait euh être une site de
dialogue et des échanges dans toutes
choses dans toutes situation et surtout
dans les situations de crise
euh on a on s'est unu d'accord avec le
temps que le temps ne déploie pas les
forces considérable
euh à la
frontièreer à la Russie donc plusieurs
choses ont été prévues mais avec du
temps sous différents prétextes sous
prétexte de cette fameuse agressivité
russe le temps a pris la décision de de
déployer quatre bataillons
euh dans les trois pays baltes Lettonie
Estonie en Lituanie et en Pologne euh en
même temps parallèlement le temps
construit le système antimissile euh qui
a été pensé
comme comme un système contre les pays
défensif contre les pays
euh comment dirje failed states
euh les pays effondrés ou oui les pays
effondrés ou les pays irresponsables euh
on parlait de l'Iran on parlait de du
Corée la Corée du Nord on parlait des
terroristes des groupes terroristes des
groupes hors état mais nos experts
militaires nos experts techniques euh
ont des soupçons euh qui sont bien
fondés sur le fait que ce système
antimissile pourrait être dirigé contre
les intérêts
stratégiques de la Fédération de Russie
c'est-à-dire contre les forces
dans la complexité si on nous prenons
cette situation dans leur dans voilà
dans dans cette complexité dans cette
généralité nous voyons que euh les
hommes politiques russes et la
population russe a euh
pour être
pessimiste l'infrastructure militaire de
le temp s'approche vers la frontière
russe et les manœuvres que vous avez
évoqué c'est juste une partie de de de
cette tendance qui nous enquiète
beaucoup parce que le temps quand même
c'est pas une organisation avec des buts
non lucratifs c'est pas une organisation
humanitaire c'est le bloc militaire le
plus puissante puissant dans l'histoire
de l'humanité c'est un bloc militaire
qui possède toutantail des armes
modernes des armes nucléaires
et quand on nous dit que élargissement
de leut temp n'est pas dirigé contre la
Russie ça nous laisse quand
même
perplexe au début de semaine dernière on
a vu deux bombardiers blackjck
s'approcher des côtes bretonne puis des
côtes anglaises euh des beaux avions
d'ailleurs c'était c'était une petite
prenade de santé c'était pour dire
bonjour vous vous étiez en train de
faire une petite livraison
oui oui oui je comprends votre
ironie je comprends votre ironie écoutez
c'est la pratique courante la pratique
absolument normale euh jamais les avions
russes ne franchissent lespace aérien
les les espaces aérien des pays
étrangers tous les vols sont effectués
dans les coulo
internationaux tous les vols sont
effectués dans les aires internationaux
sans trans dans l'espace internationaux
sans transporter je pense sans
transpondeur trans écoutez ça c'est une
bonne question parce que nous avons déjà
proposé à nos partenaires de
l'uton de d'examiner ensemble toutes les
questions qui concerne les vols dans les
régions de la mer Baltique pour
commencer parce que là non uniquement
les avions russes mais aussi les avions
de le temp se volle sans transporeur
nous avons proposé d'examiner ensemble
comment régler cette affaire et tomber
d'accord sur les vols avec transporeur
mais pour ça il faut travailler il faut
se réunir il faut évoquer euh cette
éventualité il faut que les les experts
et les cadres techniques les
spécialistes techniques se met à la
table ronde et euh qu' se parle nous
sommes ouverts à euh cette
déconflictation dans la mer dans la
région de la mer Baltique euh et nous
avons euh informé euh le temps de notre
disponibilité aujourd'hui on attend euh
la réponse mais je répète c'était
l'initiative russe comptenu ces
préoccupations des partenaires
occidentaux et de l'OT temp euh nous
avons manifesté notre bonne volonté nous
avons dit que nous sommes prêt à
discuter ce sujet par contre la Russie
comme tous les autres pays
a le droit d'effectuer les vols
militaires en pleine conformité avec la
droit internationale les règles
internationaux des vols et je vous
assure que nous respectons
euh tous ces règles et toutes nos
obligations internationales par contre
oui certains
pays de le temps s'énerve et s'inquiète
quand il voit les avions russes qui ne
ne franchissent pas leur espace a rien
mais qui volent à
quelques 100 100 km 100 quelques
dizaines 100 km écoutez ça c'est le
droit des pays de l'OTAN de lever leur
réation et pour accompagner les avions
russes je sou liigne tout ce que nous
faisons dans les airs est conforme à la
droit internationale vos deux
bombardiers n'étaient pas escortés de
d'intercepteur
quand vos bombardiers se sont fait
escorter en dehors de de en dehors de
rien du tout d'ailleurs parce que vous
vous n'étiez pas dans le dans l'espace
aérien français
euh dans ces cas-là est-ce que notre
ministre vous appelle est-ce que votre
ministre nous appelle écoutez
euh nous avons des appareils euh
militaires auprès des ambassades et a en
appareil militaire auprès de l'ambassade
de France et en appareil euh militaire
auprès de euh l'ambassade de Russie euh
les contacts entre les militaires
existent techniquement vraiment je sais
pas comment ça ça fonctionne dans cet
état de choses mais même les pilotes ils
sont munis des radios ils sont toujours
en contact
avec les services techniques sur le sol
euh voilà c'est ce que je peux vous dire
en tout cas euh à ma connaissance même
les autorités militaires françaises ont
ont reconnu que les avions russes n'ont
pas franchi l'espace aérien français il
était à côté et et peut-être euh les
avions militaires français n'étaient pas
loin pour observer c'est la pratique
normale entre les militaires de tout le
pays est-ce que je peux vous poser une
question indiscrète est-ce que ces
avions étaient chargés je peux pas vous
répondre je ne sais pas je ne pense pas
euh on va arriver sur la fin de notre
interview euh comme d'habitude on finit
par une question pour les jeunes
générations du moins un conseil pour les
jeunes
générations euh avant cette question
est-ce que vous voouyez quelque chose à
ajouter est-ce que vous avez des
questions à nous
poser écoutez
euh j'ai plusieurs questions à vous
poser mais je pense que le format de
notre émission
euh prévoit au contraire vos questions
adressées à moi-même non mais écoutez ça
serait intéressant pour moi de voir
quelle était votre appréciation
à des tendances générales euh
aujourd'hui en Europe et dans le monde
euh est-ce que vous part les peurs de
cette nouvelle guerre froide de laquelle
on parle euh oui ce sera intéressant de
sa voir quelle était votre
appréciation du
comportement des pays occidentaux en
Syrie parce que plusieurs pays sont
impliqués dans ont été impliqués dans ce
conflitl donc les questions sont
innombrables évidemment mais je pense
que nous aurons l'opportunité de
s'échanger et de parler voilà pourquoi
pour nous
euh le dialogue les contacts entre les
gens les contrats les contacts entre les
euh les civiles les les sociétés civiles
c'est très important euh voilà pourquoi
nous soutenons les les les échanges
décentralisés comme on dit des échanges
entre les régions de nos de pays qui qui
continuent malgré toutes les complexités
toutes les toute cette conjoncture
internationale pas très propice au
développement euh des relations au
niveau entreétatique euh mais les
contacts entre les sociétés civiles
entre les les gens entre les régions
entre les villes entre les municipalités
euh c'est quelque chose qui qui peut
améliorer le climat même si je dois le
dire euh les relations franco-russes
aujourd'hui euh restent toujours euh
très euh bon et euh nous sommes toujours
des partenaires euh nous continuons ce
dialogue à T niveau et c'est très
important alors la dernière question
conseil pour les jeunes générations si
vous deviez laisser une bouteille à la
mer sur Internet
oui au jeunes qui nous
regardent écoutez là je pense que les
jeunes à qui appartient l'avenir de
notre planète à qui
appartient l'avenir de l'Europe
euh doivent être responsable euh doivent
bien
calculer tout leur démarche euh et
vraiment c'est une leçon pour nous tous
il faut calculer les résultats de vos
actions on parle de la politique
extérieure aujourd'hui donc si on parle
de la politique extérieure les dernièes
décennies ont démontré combien est il
est important de calculer ce que vous
faites voilà la lébiie un exemple
euh très récent et la fois flagrant pour
moi
on a aidé à invverser la dictature de de
Kaddafi on a eu comme résultat le chaos
les pertes humaines la paopérisation de
la population la destruction du pays la
défragmentation du pays voilà donc il
faut bien calculer ce que vous faites et
dans votre vie privée et dans votre vie
professionnelle voil
artemikov merci avant de terminer cette
interview c'est un jour un peu
particulier c'est la saintserge
aujourd'hui et donc voudrais souhaiter
bonne fête à tous les Serges
et je vous remercie d'être venu aussi
vite et notre communauté vous remercie
merci beaucoup et je connais en serge
que nous connaissons tous les deux je
vais lui transmettre votre message merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]